hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und bekommt seine theorie willkommen zu
einem neuen adventskalender video
unboxing-video willst adventskalender
ein bisschen auch in nidda wir mussten
tricks lernen und lesen deswegen halten
wir es heute richtig simpel und trinken
bier mit dem adventskalender wird jeder
tag zu einem tollen spaß für die ganze
familie bin papa mal wieder sein
adventskalender türchen aufgemacht ich
habe diesen kalender in den kühlschrank
bekommen obwohl der riesengroß ist falls
sie das sehen könnt mein coaching ist ja
groß genug
in diesem adventskalender befinden sich
24 biere aus verschiedenen länder ganz
klassisch wie diesen test natürlich ein
weinglas sowie man sachen ausprobiert
ich glaube an diese dank hat immer ein
weinglas falls das jetzt kopiert ist
entschuldige ich mich vielleicht bin ich
auf dich sie inspiriert
aber ich darf den wein glas ist die
beste art das probieren und falls ihr
euch fragt was mit den restlichen bieren
passiert später kam noch ein paar
freunde vorbei und die werden auf jeden
fall ausgeht also im abfluss gekippt
weil wir spielen nur uno und trinken
nichts um leute die weihnachtszeit
beginnen und wir haben richtig bock auf
ein schönes kühles blondes beginnen wir
mit türchen nummer eins mein gott was
könnte da muss drin sein
ist es etwa ein bier und das gewässer
das
[Musik]
dieses bier kommt aus mexiko weil dieses
jahr auf mallorca deswegen weise was
herr besser heißt weil ich so
international bin gut und haben wir das
mal auf game ja okay ich rieche auf
jeden fall wichtigsten kursiere ich weiß
nicht ob es an der flasche liegt weil
sie mich an corona erinnert aber sie hat
so dieses ja irgendwie das was man
erwartet wenn man in so einem warm
urlaub ist es schmeckt auf jeden fall
gut kommt auch die gute seite ist ein
gutes bier
wir müssen aber noch 24 andere probieren
deswegen vielleicht werde ich nach dem
vierten bier besser beschreiben kino
pellet ein junges tür nummer zwei ich
bin ehrlich mit euch das ist sie einfach
eine billige ausrede zum rauchen und
trinken will sarah leafs co kommt aus
also falls ihr die biere kennt schreibt
es mir gerne in die kommentare
heißt es aus eurem homeland ist und die
homeland ist das anderes zuhause wurzeln
ihr wisst bosnien und herzegowina hat
noch nie ein bios bosnien getrunken
man trinkt ja meistens bier aus
deutschland oder aus tschechien
kelly
das riecht anders wann es da sogar
bierverkostung geworden dass nicht mal
sieger
[Musik]
ich würde sagen manchmal schmeckt bier
säuerlich und das ist so ein bier das
schmeckt schon irgendwie säuerlich
bisschen wie berliner weiße aber nicht
so doll schmeckt wie so ein bier was man
gut mit fruchtsaft oder so mischen kann
der profi hat gesprochen
ich freue mich schon wenn die leute
heute abend paar lichter aller künste
gastgeber wind weil es einfach jedes
bier anderen also war einfach um 24
verschiedene biere auf sie warten mit
türen nummer drei ist ein register
ihr werdet euch jetzt aufregen es ist
blut in korea das muss man doch safe mit
zu trinken pay lager hat carrion bier
koreanisches bier wasser gerste malz
meister geworden ist ja auch immer das
gleiche drin man braucht die indians gar
nicht sehen dann probieren wir jetzt mal
das koreanische bier
[Musik]
das kommt wohl wieder aus korea
da bin ich mal gespannt was sie im land
von bts sich so rein saufen schöne farbe
liegt nachschenken blumig irgendwie aber
das kann ja gar nicht sein
ich glaube meine meinung zu koreanischen
beers ein bisschen voreingenommen weil
nun ja ich liebe alles was aus korea
installer wird es mit zehn tür nummer
vier
ich wollte erstmal in noja verlesen
lässt ja auch immer im kopf sagt und
wieder steht in orange arnim asada ein
bier
woher kommst du 4,7 prozent ich gucke
nicht ob die prozentzahl was sind
koreanisches bier 4,34
in bosnien muss man es nicht und
schreiben oder was 4,9 okay das diagnose
ist eine italienische die brauerei mit
sitz in 18 mini auf sardinien aha dann
ist ein großer linien julia die reinheit
von dingen wir prozesse die für das bier
würde ich mich glaube ich nicht noch mal
entscheiden wenn ich die wahl hätte man
eigentlich eine wette abschließen ob ich
noch getrunken werde
glaub ich es aushalte türchen nummer
fünf das sieht bayerisches bier amore
die regatta originale hier auch mal
schreiben seit wann wie das bierbrauen
seit 1859 jahres moretti als wieder in
italienisch ist auch mal googeln wie das
hand heitz moretti familiensitz in polen
plan in italien leute das werdet ihr
nicht glauben das gehört zu heineken
group ich glaube mittlerweile gehört
jedes bier zu irgendeiner riesen
biermarke italienisches bier ein
italienisches blut das wird passen
das hat ein sehr viel goldiges aussehen
als die anderen die anderen waren eher
so gelbgold und das gold gold der duft
es sehr angenehm weich sehr mäßig riecht
es war ja wohl auch dazu sagen ich mag
so ein bisschen diese biere dieses ganz
leichte schinken aroma haben wenn dir
noch nicht viel getrunken habe dann
wisst ihr nicht weiß wovon ich spreche
das ist aber auch okay so es ist sowas
ja bis in reucher eben in diesen
räucherschinken sehr gut nikolaus
welches bier kriegen wie am 6
komm raus das ist hier eine geburt ok -
und soll diesen adventskalender ist auf
jeden fall dass das bier nicht rauskommt
presseteam drauf so gut gemacht
guck mal hier dass dein kind zeigen aus
raps spiel vietnamesisches bier karies
grad für den wwf in vietnam also für
ihre reise begleiten wollte oder
abdecken wollt was sie da so macht dann
folgte auf jeden fall auf instagram und
sohn jack mal ab was sie da tut
vietnamesisches bio ich finde es schön
dass sie sich irgendwann alle einig
waren so okay wir zeigen auf jeden fall
schwanger darf man das nicht trinken 4,9
prozent die vietnamesen wissen niemand
zeigt also das ist bis jetzt das
goldigste bier
ich bin schön wie ich nehme alles ernst
ich kann hier putzlappen adventskalender
auf macht und ich werde es ernst nehmen
angenehmer duft bisschen säuerlich
schmeckt magath ist es wieder wie so
sauer
ja ich würde sagen das bin ich aber auch
beim wein und bier ich finde das muss
man so sehr mit schmecken und weich und
so was ist nicht so ein aggressiver
geschmack nummer sieben ist doch
wünschen ein cooler kommst du nur echt
mit dem keiler achten keiler ist das
keine denn bier trinkt ist das nicht
lustig aus würzburg in deutsches bier
das würde aber sowas von youtube brust
schenken damit die kunden herausgibt mit
edlen hopfen spielst du wenn die da habe
ich auch gerade bier gemacht die weiß
dass man hoffen für bier braucht
die deutschen halten ist eine zugabe
hier habe ich noch nie in meinem leben
vorgesehen dass tyler bier gutes
geschmackserlebnis ich war aber auch
noch nie so richtig im süden von
deutschland also ich war schon mal in
münchen und stuttgart
mit dem süden beschäftigt okay leute
nummer acht ich glaube dieser ganze
adventskalenders komplett klassen gfrei
was mich sehr glücklich macht nach dem
letzten adventskalender und sowieso
haben ja wenn's blendermann sehr viel
plastik deswegen der computer bier wie
korn
die spezialität 6 prozent die anderen
haben alle so 4 oder 49 sind schwarzbier
jetzt wird hier mal die party mit
herausgerissen
woher kommst du an gleichwohl so meine
franzosen
nikon hat mich auf jeden fall schon
überzeugt
ja ja ich mag einfach so dunkle biere
also das wird heute auf jeden fall
getrunken ich finde das design auch
irgendwie voll cool ist los mit den
franzosen ein holen wir noch mal zehn
sack reis sagt es kommt aus portugal
portugal
ich weiß noch nicht viel über dich
schirme bier
das ist ein bisschen dumm klar durch wir
sind noch nicht bei mir doch das ist
hier ja ich hab gesagt empire nummer
zehn bin ich beschreibung profi also
dunkel goldene farbe duft gefällt mir
gar nicht erinnert mich an auch an
schienen der bahn nicht wünschen
das mag ich nicht die portugiesen macht
man weiter ein paar stellen die nada ich
habe das gefühl dieses bier kann sich
nicht entscheiden was es ist
ich hab das ist mein problems könnt ihr
euch auch fürs leben märkten entscheidet
euch wer sein wollt und steht dazu
dieses bier ist wie ich mit 13 ich
wollte alles sein und war somit nicht
richtig mal gucken ob ihre nummer elf
schon aus der pubertät draußen ist ein
gutes wir lieben heftes türkei nicht so
gutes thema zurzeit aber es hat aber
lange kein ass mehr also in berlin kauft
man das eigentlich in jedem spiel die
kriegt man es aber ich habe mich lange
nicht für etwas entschieden
für meine türkischen zuschauer würde ich
jetzt gerne sagen was lecker was nicht
so mein ding ich mochte aber auch nicht
dieses grüne ursula spreading ich dachte
nämlich das schmeckt so ein bisschen wie
es breit und das schmeckt halt wie
bubblegum so da
sorry dafür das darf dafür mache ich
aber baklava und döner und nein um mein
gott ich habe die neuen vergessen ist
aber auch ok für bier adventskalender
erwischt ich bin noch nicht betrunken
schreibt mir jetzt gar nicht in die
kommentare und ist schon betrunken
ich habe einfach nur die neuen vergessen
ok nummer neu würzig frischer geschmack
weg woher kommst du aus dortmund
tradition seit 1887 ist hast du ein
ungeschriebenes gesetz schreiben wir
aber definitiv drauf seid wanderung so
brauereien schule existiert dieses wie
kühler leute da könnte ich mir jetzt
sehr helle farbe sehr sehr hättet ist
ein richtig cooles platinblonde snuko
habe dafür dass es so helles hat es sehr
starken geruch überhaupt nicht
schüchtern
ich habe irgendwie gedacht ja wird sich
frischer geschmack
es schmeckt echt würfe gebraucht nach
dem deutschen reinheitsgebot nummer 12
jetzt erst bei der hälfte angekommen ok
ich kann nicht garantieren dass ich
nicht nichts getrunken wird am ende
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt ganz
exotisches bier einheimischen aus
holland amsterdam japanischen kommt aus
fordern 100 natürlich darum das grün da
kommt seit wann gibt es euch 1873 kennt
ihr noch den song von samy deluxe
bisschen golden axe ist davon sehr
neutraler geruch
komisch ich habe einige noch nie im
vergleich zu anderen biere getrunken es
lecker ok ich muss ehrlich sein ich
dachte ich kann dieses video in einem
zug durch reden und 24 biere probieren
aber ich merke jetzt schon wenn ich
weiter trinken könnte es sein dass sich
in den nächsten minuten ein ziemlich
betrunken wir sind jetzt beider 12 an
gelangen ich mache jetzt erst mal pause
ich muss es morgen oder so weiter drehen
ja meine gäste können ruhig die zwölf
bier trinken und dann ist auch gut die
anderen biere werdet ihr dann im
nächsten video sehen also ich denke
morgen wird es dann auf jeden fall
online kommt das war teil eins ich hoffe
euch hat er gefallen ich weiß dass ich
einige da draußen bestimmt wünschen dass
wir jetzt weiter trinke und schön
betrunken in der kamera herum lande aber
das möchte ich mich war das habe ich mir
auch gedacht dass ich 24 biere probieren
kann war ich schon mal bei der wein
verkosten oder bier verkauft und man
wird einfach betrunken es ist so ok ich
hoffe euch jetzt gefallen und
[Musik]